Radon is in the same group as helium and the
other noble gases. It’s in
the highly un-reactive material. However radon
has quite an importance
because it is formed by the radioactive decomposition
of some other
elements. As I mentioned you can imagine radioactivity
as a droplet of
water splitting into two, and they don’t
have to split into equal halves and
you can quite often be left with radon. Now
if you live in areas of the
world where there is radioactive material
in the minerals in the ground,
then radon as a gas, which is quite long-lived,
can come up through the
ground and accumulate in your house, and then
if you breathe it in, in
principle it can cause lung cancer, and so
there are some parts of the UK
where radon levels are much higher than others
particularly those areas
that are based on granite. But it’s very
unpredictable because if there
happens to be cracks in the rocks under your
house you can get more
radon than the guy next door and so there
has, from time to time, been
a lot of worry about radon in the air. But
for most people it’s not
something that you should really worry about.